were you just shocked how could this
happen
um yeah the same day that I heard the
show was canceled uh I I was working a
different job and my car died uh on the
day and I was like oh how can things get
any worse and then uh I've got the phone
call that the show had been canceled
and I thought this is terrible and then
who called you
um who did call me actually uh
Josh Weinstein uh who's one of our
writers and producers was the one who
let me know did you think it was coming
did you know we all knew it was coming
but we were you know optimistic
delusional whatever we we I didn't want
it to be
going that way
um but uh yeah so Josh actually didn't
call me he picked me up because my car
had was no longer working and so he was
driving me to the garage and that's when
he told me uh oh the show's been
canceled and oh truly the worst news of
the day Paul feig's mom died we all knew
Paul's mom
we loved Paul's mom she was on set all
the time so his show gets canceled and
his mom dies on the same day I think
within a day within a day or so yeah
um and your car breaks down yeah and I
mean that's that's why I start with that
yeah start with that work your way to
the import really important thing
um did you cry no you didn't cry when
you got canceled no
boy that's a that phrase takes on new
meaning now doesn't it
she seems like it like it was like holy
[ __ ] it was too good to be true you're
at such a young age or right at high
school you get on this show it's like
the critics loved it oh yeah never a bad
review not one
um I didn't cry I I was mentally
prepared for it and also as an actor
uh uh dealing with rejection dealing
with bad words you have to learn you
gotta I mean I learned instant rejection
when I started doing stand-up when I was
a teenager yeah you know like I tell
those stories and I had some great shows
but mostly bad ones right
um yeah I was not great at it uh I I had
the energy for it I enjoyed doing it but
like if you want to be a great stand-up
you've got to write new material every
day you've got to be trying out new
material five times a week uh and I
never had the
I never the the driver the patients to
do that sure so I I did my little jokey
jokes and I had fun and you know I'd
write new stuff from time to time but I
bombed a lot because I just I would get
lazy and I would see if I could expand
on existing bits or uh I would take out
the flimsiest of premises hoping it
would connect with people and then I'll
just Riff on it never panned out right
um so yes but the point is I was very
familiar with rejection and bad news
well you were I mean you've heard this
but you're brilliant on that show you're
brilliant you're brilliant you watched
that show right but you delivered you
guys all delivered the characters are
very specific very different very
defined I felt like I was there I felt
like I lived in the neighborhood it was
really a wonderful piece